personne personne ne sait quoi faire
anna karina
est ce qu'il faudrait faire quelque
chose dont on fait de son mieux
on fait du mieux qu'on peut c'est
merveilleux je vous regarde les
dévisagent que je connais
il ya mon ami marco cherqui télamon
porte bonheur
et là qu'il ya yari grogne à josiane
beaud qui lie à leïla bekhti a tellement
j'ai vu isabelle adjani je crois un
moment sur un sourire
et puis à tout le monde les invités
régionaux nationaux ou internationaux
les invités du préfet des
alpes-maritimes
ceux qui ont couché ce qu'ils ont refusé
de coucher je cours pour coucher que les
mauvaises personnes
il ya les enfants du paradis là au
merveilleux
qui sont là il ya les cinéphiles les
cinéphages
m
essai
on est là on va me brûler
expérience collective c'est assez rare
aujourd'hui vous savez d'être tous
ensemble peut-être même assis à côté de
gens qu'on ne connaît pas les gens qu'on
nous a pas présenté peut-être même des
gens d'autres milieux aux légendes autre
génération d'autres pays
couleur différente où ça n'existe pas on
est tous ensemble pour assister à une
séance de cinéma
[Musique]
bonsoir anna karina qu'elle a dans la
salle je vous salue bon choix
et bon soir à jean paul belmondo qui est
là qui est chez lui mais c'est pareil
est chez soi quand on est jean paul
belmondo 7 chez nous aussi comme bien
que logeait pour loving d'un vaisseau
qui laissent derrière eux des milliers
de ronds dans l'eau elle vend des quatre
saisons tu fais tourner deux tons et
tous les moulins de mon coeur
ce pays me tuer anwar rect c'est qu'au
statut fin et nous non
[Musique]
mesdames et mesdames mesdames et
messieurs bonsoir je suis profondément
honoré d'être la présidente de jury
cette année
aaron paul jones
merci beaucoup et bon festival si madame
le jury est maintenant au complet
vous n'en fait pas partie
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui s'est passé
quelqu'un
[Musique]
à quel moment ça a merdé
dans vos carrières non vous êtes là vous
êtes au au festival de cannes mais
clairement pas du bon côté
la notion d' ombre et lumière là est
forte ce soir le
je sais pas ce que beaucoup d'entre eux
vont participer à des films alors posons
nous les bonnes questions
joints des acteurs carabasse raihani la
grande cécile de france aussi des gens
extraordinaires qui sont la joie des
metteurs en scène même des talentueux
joua les producteurs va des techniciens
j'aurais beaucoup de gens qui ont
participé à des films ses films était il
si bon
qui sommes nous pour dire ce qui est bon
ou mauvais voilà bonne soirée à tous ce
président auquel nous déclarant le 60
30e festival national du film qui sera
ouvert
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]